so yeah Hikaru will have to take on H3  and uh okay it's it's obvious that white  is better but  black has some chances okay wow  yeah bite is much better actually yeah  black had to play King B8 because Pawn  on A7 was awesome now we have some Queen  D4 or something like this and now white  has all all time in the world to to  stabilize it yeah wow I mean actually if  bluebonn wins then he bounces back then  then it would be uh drawing this mini  match yeah which actually puts all the  more pressure on on the Magnus  Battlefield match yes yeah that's good  for the excitement of course if he wins  so Magnus causals there which was Magnus  Castle very tempting move but on the  other hand  but actually yeah now ah how is it night  I think black can't Castle you cannot  cross E8 right I think you cannot go see  it because the the King has I mean you  can try it you can try it yeah it's  quite easy